GAVIN NEWSOME:
I think it's always more fun
having the conservative guests
and having that back and forth.
In fact, that's what makes,
I think, the show work.
I agree with you about labels,
but I notice you're sitting
in front of a billboard
that says Runaway Slave.
I don't have time
to go through all of his lies,
we only have an hour.
-Uh... But let's--
-(AUDIENCE CHEERS)
I can bat them all down. Go.
I think you're a great guy,
I really hope you lose
your next election,
-because I think you're wrong
about everything.
-(AUDIENCE CHEERS)
I think you're colossally wrong
on a number of things.
-That's okay.
-But if-- Exactly.
-We're allowed to disagree
on things.
-If I banned everyone
from my show who I thought
was colossally wrong,
I would be talking to myself.
S.E. CUPP:
I think it's important,
especially when you think
someone is dangerous,
to expose that
to as many people as you can.
So giving someone like Milo
or Alex Jones, or Anne Coulter,
a platform,
that's a public service.
You said after 9/11
what we should do
is attack Muslim countries,
kill their leaders,
and convert them
to Christianity.
-Yes.
-Do you... Do you still stand
-by that moderate position?
-Absolutely fantastic policy,
I haven't heard a better one.
I love people
who stick by their guns,
even when the crowd
does not agree.
I do think that there's
an element of racism
against white individuals,
I do.
-I do see it, I think it's--
-Well, since I'm a conservative
and not a Trump person,
let me just say this.
-That's absurd.
That's fucking crazy.
-(AUDIENCE CHEERS)
The Pope
made a very strong statement
in support of my position
on climate change, not yours.
And your position
when you heard that was,
hey, let's leave the science
to the scientists.
Okay, first of all,
you're not doing that.
-But second of all...
-I am.
You're not, because 97 percent
of all scientists believe...
It's a bogus number.
-It's so not a bogus number.
-It's so a bogus number.
Okay, yours is, mine is,
yours is, mine is.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
This show, like none other,
provides an opportunity
to articulate
deeply held beliefs,
cherished ideas,
in the face of people
who are radically skeptical
about them.
Hold on,
relax, liberal audience.
Let him get his bullshit out
before you boo him!
-(LAUGHS)
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
Thank you for having me
on this show
to present the other side,
but not every network
does that all the time.
This might be
the only place in the world
-where we'd ever meet.
-(LAUGHING)
Everyone knows that
he gives people room to breathe,
and he gives people
their time to talk
and make their point, um...
and he will give you your space
to do that.
But then when you look
at the Democrats,
you see who's up
against this guy,
this unbelievably useless,
terrible candidate
-of Hillary Clinton.
-(AUDIENCE BOOS)
I feel liberated to say
whatever I believe.
And some of that
is not very popular,
I've gotten booed
several times by the audience.
BARNEY FRANK: Bill is clearly
someone who's liberal,
but he's not a party line guy.
You don't do your political
viewpoint party ideology
any favors if you assume
they're always right.